Salut ! Et bienvenue dans...
Il fait tout noir !
Quand vous vous levez la nuit pour aller aux toilettes
Est-ce que vous allumez la lumière ?
Nan !
Alors que vous seriez incapable de vous déplacer chez un inconnu...
Sans vous prendre un meuble.
Oui !
Eh ouais !
Monsieur caca boudin.
Y a des enfants qui disent "monsieur caca boudin".
Ils parlent d'Anis je pense, c'est pas moi.
Je reprends le fil de ce qu'on disait.
Chez soi on développe un super-pouvoir.
On est capable de se faire un café les yeux bandés je crois, non ?
Ouais !
Est-ce que tu penses que Freddy Gladieux possède ce pouvoir ?
Je sais pas !
Eh bah c'est ce qu'on va vérifier tout de suite !
Est-il un super-héros du quotidien ?
C'est parti !
On sonne.
Monsieur Gladieux ?
Il a l'air bien réveillé.
Il sait qu'on vient filmer un truc chez lui.
Mais il ne sait pas quoi.
Et il croit que c'est une surprise de ouf.
Alors qu'en fait c'est pas une surprise de ouf.
Sommes nous au bon étage ?
C'est bien lui, j'avais peur que ça soit pas la bonne porte.
Ça va monsieur Gladieux ? On est bien chez vous, c'est ça ?
C'est pas grave si a un moment euh... j'ai une érection matinale ?
Ça dérange personne ?
Non, non, ça va.
J'ai un peu froid.
Je peux...
C'est con, on verra pas vos jolies cuisses...
Ouais mais c'est pas grave.
Moi ça me gêne, vas-y, ouais.
On peut faire un insert dessus.
Nan, c'est vrai que c'est un peu gênant hein...
D'être comme ça euh...
Jambes nues.
Ça fait longtemps que vous vivez ici ?
Je suis né...
Quasiment dans cet appart.
Mais vous vivez seul ? Vous ne vivez plus avec vos parents ?
Depuis peu de temps, y a mes parents chez moi.
D'accord. Vous hébergez vos parents.
Du coup vous avez dû reprendre des habitudes d'adolescent ?
Genre cacher vos DVD porno...
Si on trouve un DVD, c'est pas le mien.
C'est que c'est celui de mes parents et du coup ça va vraiment me gêner.
Quelle est votre morning routine par exemple ?
Être un peu trop...
Sur Insta, je pense. Regarder des story.
Vous vous réveillez et téléphone ?
Téléphone pendant un bon moment.
Douche et je sors dans la foulée.
Et je prends un petit déj' dehors, généralement.
Et donc la première chose que vous faites le matin, c'est les story...
Après donc c'est le petit... le petit café
Le petit brossage de dents ? J'imagine que vous vous brossez les dents ?
Jamais !
Est-ce que tout ce que vous nous avez dit est vrai monsieur Gladieux ?
On est bien chez vous du coup ?
Oui. T'as pas vu mon nom en bas ?
T'as pas vu 5 noms sur la boîte aux lettres ?
J'ai vu "Banderas"
Et je me suis pas dit que c'était Antonio Banderas qui habitait là.
Quoi ?
Bien écoutez si on est bien chez vous, vous allez pouvoir nous le prouver.
Alors, je vais vous demander de me suivre.
Ok !
Et vous allez...
Ouvrir cette mallette.
Que t'as ramené ?
Y a quoi là dedans ?
Je peux toucher d'abord ?
Sans voir ?
Vous aimez bien toucher sans voir les trucs ?
C'est une mallette de sado maso ?
Presque.
C'est assorti à votre tenue.
C'est assorti, c'est cool.
Ok !
Vous allez pouvoir nous faire votre morning routine.
Ok.
Les yeux fermés.
Le mec il est déjà deter.
Il est déjà chaud.
Bon on va quand même t'équiper au cas où.
Parce que ça serait quand même dommage...
Que tu te fasses bobo. Et en plus ça te fait une belle gueule.
Tu confirmes que tu vois rien ?
Non, alors non seulement j'ai ce truc là...
Mais en plus ça presse dessus.
Donc là pour le coup, je vois vraiment... je vois vraiment rien quoi.
Il fait tout noir ?
Il fait tout noir.
Et c'est parti pour...
Il faut savoir que même chez moi...
Comme tous les gens, je me prends quand même des fois des poignées quoi.
Ah, vous êtes un super-héros nul quoi, c'est ça que vous dîtes ?
Alors allez-y, couchez vous et puis on va pouvoir commencer votre petite journée.
Alors, généralement je dors... comme ça !
Naturellement.
D'accord.
Après normalement je fais ça et je check mes notifs.
Allez-y. Essayez d'aller sur un réseau social.
Les réseaux sociaux c'est à droite.
Insta ?
Presque.
C'est peut-être plus haut ?
C'est genre... Insta ?
Presque.
Insta ?
C'est marrant parce que vous avez pas une fois lancé une appli.
Mais vous avez des doigts euh...
Pas tactiles en fait.
Vous nous avez menti sur la première étape de votre morning routine.
Ok, là je vais dans la cuisine.
Des mugs.
Ils sont là.
Je dois deviner c'est quel mug.
Quotidien ?
Golden Moustache.
Je check.
La machine est là.
J'ai pas retiré le percolateur.
C'est propre ?
C'est propre.
Oui.
Café déca, c'est le matin.
Je prends pas un déca le matin.
Je prends un café classique.
Ça va, non je suis impressionné.
Ok.
Je le mets bien en dessous.
Et là généralement je regarde les enfants jouer en face.
Parce qu'il y a une école.
Du coup c'est lequel ton enfant préféré ?
C'est euh...
C'est lui mon enfant préféré.
Donc la morning routine du petit déj' de chez vous est prête.
Vous n'avez plus qu'à boire votre morning routine du café.
J'ai envie de le boire tellement il est réussi votre café, c'est incroyable.
C'est le moment...
De faire un Puissance 4 avec Anis.
Je te laisse prendre les jaunes.
Les ?   - Les jaunes.
C'est deux jaunes ?
Parce que là si c'est deux jaunes c'est extraordinaire.
C'est deux rouges en fait.
Anis je vous laisse choisir votre bandeau.
On voit rien en fait.
C'est parti.
Pour le Puissance 4 les yeux bandés.
Freddy à vous l'honneur.
Cet échec.
C'est très bien parti pour vous deux.
Si tu te concentres sur le son, t'arrives à voir si on les met là ou là.
Et là il les met tous à droite.
T'es fou, tu les mets tous là.
Non mais joue à gauche un peu !
Prends des risques Anis !
Y a pas Puissance 4 là ?
Bah si, mais pour Freddy.
C'est vrai ?!
Regarde !
Il a même pas exprès je suis sûr.
Bah non !
Comment ça j'ai pas fait exprès ?
Ça va !
Chaque matin je mets des raclés au Puissance 4 aux gens rageux.
Vous avez droit à une petite récompense. Vous avez droit à une petite collation.
Surtout qu'il m'a battu à Puissance 4.
C'est ça !
Tu sais que j'ai demandé ce matin quand vous veniez, est-ce que vous pouviez m'apporter un petit déj'.
En fait dans votre morning routine il y avait pas de petit déj'.
Je prends le petit déj' dehors généralement.
Oui bah c'est pour ça que je vous demandais un petit déj'.
Vous allez avoir 3 gobelets.
Avec des trucs dedans.
Vous allez devoir mélanger 2 de ces gobelets.
Y a des chances pour que ça soit bon...
Si vous vous gourez pas.
Dans un des gobelets vous aurez de l'eau.
Dans un des gobelets vous aurez de la grenadine.
Et un gobelet avec de l'huile d'olive.
Y a aussi des gens qui prennent de l'huile d'olive le matin.
Exactement.
A Cuba je crois qu'ils font ça hein.
Alors vous savez pas ce que vous faites mais c'est ma bite.
Ah pardon !
Putain, je suis désolé.
Parce que c'est ici généralement que j'ouvre mon tiroir.
Pour prendre une cuillère.
Celui qui est le plus rempli j'imagine que c'est de l'eau.
Y a un truc de...
Ça c'est frais, c'est de l'eau.
Bah je suis navré les gars.
Je dois savoir ce qui est de l'huile ou de la grenadine.
Anis est d'origine algérienne, il sait que...
Ça ne se gâche pas de l'huile d'olive.
Je pense que le verre le moins rempli c'est de l'huile d'olive.
Ça c'est l'huile d'olive parce qu'il y en a moins.
Et ça c'est la grenadine.
Vous avez changé d'avis au dernier moment j'ai l'impression.
C'est parfait.
Bah je me rince la bouche comme tout le monde hein.
C'est-à-dire comme ça.
Ah putain !
Arrête !
Voilà c'est officiel je suis humide.
J'ai eu peur de cracher sur la caméra.
Bah vous l'avez fait.
Non !
Ça va mieux ?
Oui.
Non ! Putain !
Apparement y a Anis qui est là nu, on fait l'amour.
Il est où ?
Ah ! C'est mouillé là !
Mais oui, vous avez jeté de l'eau partout.
Ah merde.
Le défi tennis monsieur Gladieux...
C'est un défi que chaque participant à ce programme... font.
Donc là vous avez de la chance, vous allez rentrer...
Dans un classement...
Je vais être le premier c'est simple.   - Mondial.
Dans la même minute...
Vous allez faire rebondir cette balle et la rattraper la plus de fois possible.
Ok d'accord, il faut que je me concentre du coup.  - Oui !
Donc vous attendez mon décompte.
Super.
Donc on a une minute, c'est parti !
Ça revient à zéro ?
C'est pas mal !
Il vous reste 18 secondes.
Il vous reste 6 secondes.
J'essaie de viser Aurél !
Pour vous féliciter vous avez droit à une collation d'huile d'olive.
Check Anis !
Est-ce que Freddy est un super-héros du quotidien ?
Franchement, ouais.
Franchement ouais et Freddy tu as donc droit de signer le livre d'or de l'émission.
Les yeux... les yeux bandés ?
Oui.  - Oui.
Les yeux bandés.
Depuis peu de temps y a mes parents chez moi.
Du coup vous avez dû cacher vos DVD porno...
Si tu trouve un DVD, c'est pas le mien, c'est celui de mes parents.
Je fais la première page ?
C'est vous qui... si vous voulez, où vous voulez, c'est...
C'est vous qui... c'est vous qui décidez où vous écrivez dans ce livre d'or hein.
Ça écrit pas très droit mais en tout cas ça écrit bien.
Tu peux le lire ? On va voir si c'est bien écrit.
Un vrai...
Batteur...
Non, bonheur.
De battre Yannis...
Anis !
Au Puissance 8.
Si tu dis ça c'est que je l'ai très bien écrit c'est ça ?
Et vous avez signer Arturo Brachetti par contre.
Vous vous êtes trompé de gars.
Vous avez le droit d'enlever... votre masque !
En fait le plus dur c'est de porter un masque.
En fait c'est ça le truc le plus...
Un masque ou un casque ?
Bah moi toujours hein euh...
Depuis le début moi je suis comme ça.
Anis a pas voulu le faire par contre.
Freddy, Anis m'a emmené chez toi pour tester tes super-pouvoirs...
Chez qui tu as envie de m'emmener toi ?
Jean Dujardin !
Un autre pote à toi.   - Gilles Lellouche !
Un gars que tu connais.
Albert Dupontel.
C'est pas un pote à toi.
Chez Pana.
Chez Pana ?
On va chez Pana ?
Bon bah j'espère qu'il voudra bien.
Merci bien.
Allez ciao !
Bah c'était sympa en tout cas.
Et ça fait plaisir de voir que Freddy aussi est un super-héros du quotidien.
Tu lui mettrais combien sur 10 ?
Je lui mettrais un petit 8.
Un petit 8 ?   - Ouais.
Ok bah notez Freddy dans les commentaires sur 10.
Et abonnez vous à toutes les chaînes respectives de tous ces gens.
Tu vas remettre des trucs sur ta chaîne Anis ou pas ?
Euh si vous vous abonnez, ouais.
Abonnez vous, à la mienne, à celle de Freddy.
Y a pas de piège normalement.
Bah là le piège c'est qu'on va forcément croiser quelqu'un.
Et qu'on est en slip dans une cité du 93.